ce soir au sommaire 2e égale m6 langage
du corps des animaux écriture tous les
langages décrypté par la science entre
nos chiens échange de véritable carte de
visite de quelle manière et que
comprennent t-il lorsque nous leur
parlons découvrez comment certains
singes sont capables de former des
messages très précis en combinant
plusieurs cris le perroquet peut parler
pourtant il n'a pas de cordes vocales
comment fait-il
inconsciemment ou pas lorsque nous
parlons nous nous plaçons à une certaine
distance de notre interlocuteur et nous
faisons des gestes pour accompagner
notre parole pourquoi sans ce langage
corporel arriverions nous à nous
comprendre aussi bien pour le savoir mac
lesggy s'est prêté à un drôle de test
nous écrivons tous les jours mais savez
vous que la première écriture a été
inventé il ya 6000 ans d'où viennent les
26 lettres de notre alphabet déchiffrer
un mot est une tâche complexe
découvrez les facultés étonnante de
notre cerveau pour y parvenir en une
fraction de seconde les secrets du
langage des hommes et des animaux c'est
maintenant dans ugly side on dit souvent
en parlant de son animal de compagnie il
ne lui manque que la parole pourtant
vous allez découvrir que les animaux
sont capables de communiquer entre eux
que vos chiens ont un langage corporel
très efficace que certains singes
utilise même une véritable langue est
que des perroquets reproduisent la nôtre
à la perfection écoutez c'est incroyable
pourtant il n'ya aucun trucage
[Musique]
quand des chiens se rencontrent que
peuvent-ils bien se raconter antoine
bouveresse vétérinaire nous donne
quelques clés pour les comprendre
[Musique]
voilà donc là ça en train de jouer
par contre ils se connaissaient pas il
ya deux minutes donc tel qui en a un des
deux qui va se rendre compte que le jeu
est un petit peu trop violent alors à ce
moment-là ils s'arrêteront ils se
remettront à distance pour se re
calibrer
et donc là on voit qu'il ya il montre
les dents ils font beaucoup de bruit ils
peuvent grenier un petit peu faire comme
ça mais c'est tout dans le jeu donc leur
communication elle est fiable et adapté
du coup il arrive à jouer correctement
sans qu'il y ait de
d'anicroches chez de quoi parle le même
langage donc il y aura jamais de souci
avec eux mais comment ces deux chiens
qui se connaissent depuis quelques
minutes à peine peuvent-ils se
comprendre il n'y a pas de paroles n'y a
pas de langage chez le chien mais il ya
quand même une communication auditive
c'est à dire que ils s'échangent des
choses en grognant en aboyant en mai
une grande grande partie de la
communication elle se fait par les
postures qu'ils prennent quand ils se
présentent les chiens ont toute une
palette d'attitude qui leur permettent
d'informer leurs congénères les odeurs
joue aussi un rôle essentiel ensuite ils
vont se renifler ils vont échanger ainsi
les informations sur leur sexe leur âge
leur statut sexuel est ce que cette
femelle est en chaleur ils vont se
renifler
se tourner autour prendre des
informations olfactives au niveau de
l'anus ça y est c'est présenté c'est
fini les odeurs sont pour les chiens
l'équivalent de nos cartes de visite et
pour signifier leur état d'esprit aussi
bien aux autres chiens cas nous les
humains ils utilisent leur queue
elle agite la queue pour dire ouais je
suis cool j'ai envie de jouer je suis
sympa on peut ainsi savoir si le chien
est content et excité curieux mais aussi
stressé démonstration
voilà elle n'est pas à l'aise elle doit
on peut pousser et du coup là que passe
en dessous parce qu'elle a peur mais au
fait comment les chiens comprennent t-il
le langage humain je préfère
vraiment comme ça ça m'intéresse à
l'interpellent il sait que c'est plutôt
une parole qui est relativement
intéressante et regarder ce qu'il se
passe quand le vétérinaire change de ton
voulzy goody petit timothée que tu as
volé
en clair le chien ne comprend pas le
sens de nos maux mais il capte le temps
de nos phrases ainsi que nos mimiques et
notre gestuelle mais si les chiens
savent parfaitement communiqué sans
recourir à un langage vocale vous allez
découvrir des animaux qui eux sont
capables de dialoguer à la manière des
humains nous sommes en bretagne au coeur
de la forêt de brocéliande
ici l'écologiste alban lemasson étudie
une espèce de singe originaires
d'afrique de l'ouest
lemon de caen belle sans doute l'une des
espèces animales qui possède après
l'homme la langue la plus complexe
vous allez voir que ces singes
communiquent entre eux au moyen de crise
bien précis
là on vient d'entendre un échange vocal
entre deux femelles celle ci a initié
celle là a répondu c'est un une
interaction sociale à base de cris de
contact qui se présente comme une
conversation primitive en respectant des
règles comme celle de nos conversations
humaines ne pas se couper la parole
crier à tour de rôle
exactement comme chez l'homme ils ont
appris à ne pas se couper la parole
notre chercheur a aussi découvert un
mimétisme vocales entre des individus
amis
donc deux femelles amies elles vont
avoir la même façon d'émettre leurs cris
de contact c'est ce que l'on voit ici
le parallèle avec l'homme c'est ce que
par exemple on va trouver dans les cours
de récré à l'école les amis ont tendance
à parler de la même façon adopté leur
propre langage et les scientifiques ont
fait récemment une découverte incroyable
à l'état sauvage quand il ya un danger
ces singes sont capables d'informer
leurs congénères du type précis de
menaces écoutez
contrôleurs présents à l'heure de
léopard il voyait m l'ecri craque
lorsqu'on leur présente un leurre d'elle
il est même décrit up
craque
encore plus étonnant ces singes sont
capables de combiner ces sons pour créer
des cris et même des phrases complexes
exemple avec le son ou le crack ou
locaux coup
ils le font quand ils veulent informer
de n'importe quel danger venant du sol
pour le krak oo et de n'importe quel
danger venant du ciel pour le au cou
ainsi lorsqu une antilope s'approche du
groupe le mal aimé le son crack ou qui
indique qu'un intrus venant du sol et à
force de les étudier notre chercheur
c'est maintenant décodées des
combinaisons de son correspondant à des
phrases évolué bon ben on recourt aux
crocos krak oo krak oo krak oo ça veut
dire attention voisins alors peut-on
affirmer que ces singes parle d'un
langage ce qui jusqu'à présent était
réservé à l'homme
de langage c'est un certain nombre de
propriétés c'est la capacité à converser
avec ses amis c'est la capacité à copier
la voix de ses amis c'est la capacité à
encoder des messages sur l'environnement
extérieur et dans ce cas là oui c'est
une forme primitive de langage ces sages
sont donc capables de dialoguer même si
leurs cris sont très éloignées de la
voix humaine
mais d'autres animaux n'ont pas leur
langue dans leur poche
à paris roger jacqueline sont très fiers
de nous présenter enzo leur perroquet
gris du gabon il a 19 ans et c'est sans
doute l'oiseau le plus bavard de france
vous pensez qu'il ya un trucage et bien
non enzo connais plus de 200 phrase à
partir du mot émission
il fait ses phrases par exemple je lui
ai déjà dit plein de fois tu vas rentrer
à la cage là il a dit tu vas rentrer
l'émission
lui ai dit c'est difficile quand quand
il fait la gamme hausse est difficile
alors là c'est difficile l'émission donc
avec le mot émission il a peut-être 7
8/10 phrase
[Musique]
et oui enzo c'est beaucoup de travail un
reportage mais comment un oiseau peut-il
reproduire la vie humaine aussi
parfaitement
contrairement à nous les oiseaux n'ont
pas de larynx ni de cordes vocales pour
émettre des sons et dans le cas des
perroquets pourparlers les oiseaux
possède un organe appelé la syrie située
à l'embranchement de leurs bronches au
passage de l'air la sierentz vibre et
aimer une large palette de fréquences
puis c'est en modulant la position de
lorbek et de leur langue que les oiseaux
chantent ou reproduisent la voix humaine
c'est le perroquet cette prouesse est
possible grâce à son cerveau qui possède
des structures de l'écouté et de la
production vocale très performante
mais au fait ce perroquet très bavard
comprend t-il ce qu'il dit
enzo est capable d'associer les sons
avec le chief ex particulier comme de
dire à l'eau et de faire une
conversation qui correspond à une
conversation téléphonique
[Musique]
il est capable aussi de dire des choses
comme c'est difficile l'émission
précisément au moment où on est en train
de le filmer
donc il comprend que l'émission un
rapport en tout cas avec le fait qu'il
ya des caméras des gens qui connaît pas
qui les a encouragé à parler il est
clair qu'on peut parler d'intelligence
et les perroquets
en clair enzo ne comprend pas forcément
mot-à-mot ce qu'il dit mais il associe
des phrases à leur contexte vous l'avez
compris que ce soit en copiant notre
voix au moyen de grognements ou de cris
qui forme des dialogues les animaux
savent communiquer presque comme nous
notre façon de bouger notre corps et
notre gestuelle envoient des messages à
nos interlocuteurs ces gestes accompagne
notre parole mais lorsque nous les
faisons que se passe-t-il dans notre
cerveau à partir de quand commençons
nous à les utiliser pourquoi garde ton
toujours une certaine distance lorsque
nous parlons à une personne nos
spécialistes décrypte le langage de
notre corps
des gestes de la main d expression de
joie de tristesse de surprises nous
faisons tous des gestes et des mimiques
pour les désigner on parle de
communication non verbale
mac lesggy s'est rendue à lille dans le
laboratoire de loris skhirat aura
chercheuse en psychologie sociale
la préparer une expérience pour nous
montrer à quel point ces gestes sont
indispensables dans notre quotidien
alors l'oea va vous transmettre un
itinéraire il devrait mémoriser et nous
reproduire ensuite sur une feuille de
papier
je suis tout ouïe donc en sortant de
cette salle vous allez prendre sur la
droite aléas explique un chemin à mac
lesggy mais sans faire le moindre geste
vous arrivez sur une passerelle vous
traversé la passerelle à la passerelle
vous retrouvons reprenez votre droite
une garde escalier qui descend qui vous
amènera entre pouvoir waouh c'est vite
dit
encore à droite au moment de
retranscrire le résultat il semblerait
que max soit un peu perdue elle la
passerelle à la sortie je tourne un coup
à gauche
c'est ça
et sont et non mac os après la
passerelle il fallait partir à droite
pour mac ne pas avoir accès à quelque
chose de visible un itinéraire qui
devient visible au travers les gestes
peuvent être qu'ils ne reconnaissent pas
qu'il n'arrive pas à construire
véritablement l'itinéraire voir les
gestes de notre interlocuteur nous a
donc réellement à mieux comprendre son
propos d'ailleurs dès que les a indiqu
hamac un autre chemin cette fois ci avec
les gestes mac va comprendre beaucoup
mieux là je vois un bâtiment d'ici et un
bâtiment qui est en face de moi mais je
vais pour palace m'a paru plus clair la
gestualité est particulièrement
importante lorsqu'on communique des
contenus qui sont des contenus concrets
dans lesquels il y a beaucoup d'image et
des recours d'action ces gestes
permettent de rendre visibles les images
que peu l'ont vu communiqué la sauveté
geste que nous effectuons consciemment
ou pas constitue donc une communication
parallèle au langage qui est souvent
indispensable à la compréhension du
message derrière mais peut-on vraiment
parler d'un langage à la pitié
salpêtrière
richard levin neurologue nous explique
ce qu'il se passe dans notre cerveau
quand nous faisons des gestes nos
intentions qu'il soit pour les gestes ou
pour les mots viennent de la même région
du cerveau c'est le lobe frontal qui
décident compte ce que l'on fait est
volontaire pour faire bouger les muscles
du bras par exemple le cerveau fait
appel au cortex moteur mais l'origine du
geste son intention par du lobe frontal
la même zone que celle de la parole
c'est la preuve que ces gestes sont bel
et bien une forme de communication mais
que se passerait-il si nous en étions
totalement privée
évidemment notre intention serait
probablement moins bien comprise car le
langage du corps langage des émotions et
compris plus rapidement que le langage
lui-même qui fait appel à un système de
nombreux neurones qui s'enchaînent les
uns derrière les autres et qui se prend
un temps beaucoup plus long pour
comprendre l'ensemble de la valeur d'un
discours ces gestes nous les percevons
tous très rapidement mais comment avons
nous appris à nous en servir et à les
décoder
on a un système dans le cerveau qui est
un système d'imitation qu'on appelle un
système miroir et c'est grâce à ces
systèmes de neurones que l'on peut
progressivement apprendre à communiquer
parce que l'on va apprendre à imiter on
va apprendre à imaginer le geste on va
apprendre à le déclencher le cerveau des
bébés est donc programmé pour reproduire
les gestes et les mimiques des adultes
cette capacité naturelle peut même être
encouragée pour aider les jeunes enfants
qui ne maîtrise pas encore la parole à
se faire comprendre plus facilement
nous sommes à versailles dans une crèche
ici on a développé une méthode
surprenante regardez les enfants font
des gestes étranges
[Musique]
commandes oui c'est bien corentin
oui c'est bien tu fais de l'eau ici les
éducateurs apprennent tout une série de
gestes aux bébés pour accompagner les
notions les plus simples du quotidien
une méthode né aux états unis dans les
années 80 est inspiré par le langage des
signes que les sourds muets utilise pour
communiquer est ce que tu veux de l'eau
gaspard les gestes permettent de mieux
comprendre
les mots pour les enfants et donc de
mieux les exprimer parce que ça leur
permet de mieux visualiser le sens du
mot par exemple manger et bien du coup
du fait de faire le geste et il
s'associe l'action qui est rapporté du
coup on sait que les enfants utilisent
les gestes vont avoir un vocabulaire
plus riches par la suite
les gestes qui viennent pas accompagné
les premiers mots ont exactement la même
fonction que les dessins d'un livre
d'image il apporte une représentation
visuelle qui soutient la compréhension
et qui facilitera donc l'expression du
mot
il existe une autre forme de
communication non verbale presque
inconsciente que l'on appelle la
proxémie c'est la distance qui nous
sépare de notre interlocuteur
retour à lille mac lesggy pense se
prêter à une nouvelle expérience de
mémorisation d'un itinéraire mais cette
fois ci il va avoir affaire à gauthier
un interlocuteur particulièrement
envahissant permis 167 génial que vous
asseoir au moteur way sans me prévenir
il va rompre les distances d'usagé
gauthier lui parle en se collant à lui
et le touch regardez mac lesggy semble
très perturbé par ce comportement à tel
point qu'ils n'arrivent plus à se
concentrer sur l'itinéraire qu'on lui
explique
d'accord on a très bien
agi
à ce moment là ça provoquait on a vu
très clairement une réaction un petit
peu de défense schéma qui veut reprendre
ses distances et donc mcb essayer de le
faire en
finalement essayons de reculer le tronc
ou en se mettant un temps un petit peu
en retrait sur la chaise en effet les
distances sociales sont très codifié et
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas respectées la
communication est perturbé les
spécialistes ont observé quatre sortes
de distances différentes que nous
respectons tous sans même nous en rendre
compte
la distance intime qui va de 15 à 45 cm
celle des couples ou lorsque l'on drague
par exemple la distance personnel
jusqu'à 1 mètre 20 pour les
conversations entre amis
avec des inconnus on respecte une
distance sociale qui va de 1 mètre 20 à
3 mètres 70 et au delà c'est la distance
public utilisé lorsque l'on s'adresse à
un groupe ou à une haute personnalité
ses distances correspondent aux codes
sociaux de la plupart des pays
occidentaux
mais elles peuvent varier selon les pays
où les cultures
tout va bien tout va bien c'est vrai que
c'est un peu déstabilisant effectivement
d'avoir gothique qui arrive comme ça
aussi prêt mais ça montre bien que
et les gestes et la distance qu'on a
vis-à-vis de l'interlocuteur sa partie
d'une bonne communication entre les
individus tout à fait tout à fait vous
avez bien compris et ben voila je repars
fort ses connaissances merci beaucoup
gauthier merci le ricin au revoir à rien
je vous en prie
vous l'avez vu qu'il s'agisse de nos
gestes de nos mimiques ou de notre
position notre corps et dont beaucoup
plus bavard qu'on ne l'imaginent
notre civilisation moderne repose sur
une technique tout le monde connaît
l'écriture mais savez-vous qu'il a
inventée à quoi ressemblaient les
premières écritures
certaines écritures comme le chinois
n'ont pas d'alphabet son talent très
différente de la nôtre comment notre
cerveau décrypte-t-il les mots lorsque
nous lisons e égal m6 vous dit tout
l'écriture est omniprésente dans notre
quotidien mais tout vient tél avec sarah
la case archéologue et sept classes de
primaire remontons à son origine alors
l'écriture est apparue en mésopotamie la
mésopotamie c'est une grande région qui
est situé ici est la partie qui va nous
intéresser plus c'est ici c'est la
civilisation sumérienne notamment qui
correspond aujourd'hui à l'actuel irak
c'est dans cette région qu un peuple
très ingénieux les sumériens ont inventé
l'écriture il ya près de six mille ans
et si elle a été mise au point s'est
pour une raison bien précise
à quoi ça peut servir à l'écrit de
l'écriture
tout à fait si les hommes ont commencé à
écrire c'est qu'ils ont eu besoin de
cette écriture pour se transmettre des
messages et des messages bien
particulier des messages liés au
commerce on va commencer à noter on va
commencer à faire des contrats entre les
hommes si l'on invente l'écriture c'est
donc pour faire du business pour garder
une trace écrite des échanges on invente
un code composé de pictogrammes les
pictogrammes ce sont des dessins qui
représentent quelque chose est en tout
début les hommes ont dessiné pour
représenter donc par exemple on va voir
qu'est ce que ça peut être
vous avez deviné
oui une image un boeuf un taureau qu'est
ce que ça peut être ce pictogramme
doublé oui des céréales vous l'aurez
compris à chaque symbole correspond un
mot quant au nombre ils sont représentés
par ces grosses empreintes nos scribes
en herbe passe maintenant à la pratique
sur des tablettes en argile car à
l'époque le papier n'existait pas encore
et voilà le résultat
et trente six mille poissons
g
[Musique]
je
des pictogrammes comme cela on en
utilise et près de 1000 différents mais
dessinée dans l'argile cela demande du
temps et une certaine dose de talent
alors il ya quatre mille huit cents ans
pour plus de facilité les sumériens
standardise leur écriture tous les
symboles se forment désormais grâce à
cet outil le coin c'est la naissance de
l'écriture cunéiforme
démonstration si on veut faire juste la
forme de coin c'est pas l'impression
voilà ensuite les différents éléments
coin peuvent être reliés entre eux juste
en traçant
premier les éléments
difficile de reconnaître les
pictogrammes d'origine pourtant le
principe reste le même à chaque symbole
correspond un mot de nos jours encore
quelques écritures comme le chinois
fonctionne sur ce principe
regardez en chinois ja caractère
correspond une idée ou une signification
par exemple je vous donne un exemple
où
ça ça veut dire l'homme qui avait fait
deux deux jambes qui joue sur la terre
voilà et après si j'ajoute un trait
horizontal
l'avenir grandes voix là et ici j'ajoute
encore
un trait de veut dire ce qui est au
dessus de l'homme et qui est plus grande
de l'homme ça veut dire le ciel pour
écrire le chinois il faut connaître
entre 2000 et 3000 signes que l'on
appelle des idéogrammes il dérive eu
d'aussi de pictogrammes très anciens
regardez par exemple comment ce dessin a
donné au fil du temps le caractère
chinois signifiant poisson
notre écriture à nous elle n'a rien à
voir elle est basée sur un système
inventé il ya trois mille deux cents ans
l'alphabet mais à qui le doit-on le
premier à ta alphabet a été inventée
donc parler fini siens qui se situait à
peu près entre le liban et la syrie
alors les phéniciens en fin de compte
vont garder des signes mais de ces
signes ils vont juste extraire le son de
ce signe donc juste avec quelques
quelques signes quelques dessins on va
pouvoir retranscrire tous les sons et
tous ces sons mis bout-à-bout vont
pouvoir former des mots auparavant un
signe correspondait à un mot avec
l'alphabet un signe ou une lettre
correspond à un son à eau m r ce système
basé sur des sons et révolutionnaire
grâce à lui il suffit d'une vingtaine de
lettres pour former n'importe quel mot
et c'est de cet alphabet phéniciens que
descendre notre alphabet actuelle
l'alphabet que nous utilisons est un
alphabet latin donc a pour origine le
monde romain mais le monde romain a créé
son alphabet en empruntant quelques
lettres à l'alphabet grec qui lui même
avait emprunté à l'alphabet phénicien
les romains écrivait en latin et si nos
lettres sont aujourd'hui toujours les
mêmes il ya pourtant une différence de
taille les romains n'avaient pas besoin
d'espacé ou de ponctuation car en latin
on peut mélanger les mots sans changer
le sens d'une phrase mais en français
c'est différent regardez cette phrase si
on mangeait les enfants écrivent on l'a
maintenant comme les romains plus d
espace ni de ponctuation et en lettres
capitales car à l'époque les minuscules
n'existe pas encore et si on mangeait
les enfants non seulement c'est plus
difficile à lire mais surtout le sens
change radicalement
c'est pour cette raison que la
ponctuation se développent pendant la
renaissance lorsque le français remplace
le latin comme langue officielle
pour autant de décrypter des mots
autrement dit lire reste une tâche
complexe comment notre cerveau et
parvient-il quand vous lisez un mot il
va d'abord être décodés par les aires
visuelles primaires c'est-à-dire
l'arrière du cerveau puis le mot va être
envoyé aux airs du langage directement
césaire du langage sont situés dans le
lobe temporal gauche et la plupart des
gens et à partir de là l'information va
être envoyé pour être pour traiter le
sens le son est l'articulation face à un
mot inconnu notre cerveau effectué un
décryptage lettre par lettre en les
associant aux sons auxquels elles
correspondent mais pour les mots les
plus utilisés
notre cerveau possède une capacité
étonnante vous ne les transcoder plus
mais vous les reconnaissez finalement
reconnaître un mot c'est un peu comme
reconnaître un visage il faut le
connaître par coeur quand vous regardez
quelqu'un vous n'allez pas vous dire
c'est ses yeux c'est son nez c'est sa
bouche ah oui tiens ces trucs si je le
connais c'est lui vous allez le
regardeur lanthier et le reconnaître en
un éclair pour un mot ça doit être la
même chose eh oui on ne lit pas
forcément toutes les lettres la preuve
essayez de lire cette phrase
l'ordre des lettres dans un mot n'a pas
d'importance l'ordre des lettres d'un
mot n'a pas d'importance vous avez
réussi à la lire sans difficulté
pourtant la plupart des lettres sont
mélangés comment est ce possible
si vous avez une partie de mon visage
qui est caché vous avez quand même me
reconnaître le mot c'est exactement la
même chose s'il est un petit peu
chamboulé on va quand même le
reconnaître ici notre cerveau reconnaît
la première et la dernière lettre du mot
humain est il de ville l'ordre des
lettres du milieu même inversée mais si
on les mélange tout cela devient bien
sûr impossible vous savez maintenant
comment notre cerveau lit et d'où vient
l'écriture cette extraordinaire
invention vieille de six mille ans et
qui gardent aujourd'hui toute son
utilité